[Music]
what's all about masters of sex
congratulations on that role now this is
a role did you understand what was
involved when you signed on because
nudity was involved there was no script
when I said yes I spoke to Michelle
Ashford and Sarah Timmerman who were the
creators of it and they said that they
were they wanted to write this character
for me and there would be nudity and how
did I feel about that and I said not you
know not great but but I I would do it
and they made it seem like I would have
total control like you know and then you
have to go through negotiating a nudity
contract which is quite extensive and
and a little scary I mean you have to it
gets down to you know Allison Janney
will only show left side boob not right
side boob ass can be shot from above but
not down but you know like you could you
can and as these lawyers working at ass
I was I'm talking with my lawyer about
this how I felt I was just yeah we got
left side boob they're giving us a hard
time on right side boob
I want to know what's wrong with your
right side that is so crazy you have you
that you had to work out all that very
flustered I've like I've never done this
before I don't know what I want is I
want it to be very dark and I want you
know the DP to be the better I just I
just wanted to be lit well and and not
show more than was entirely necessary
have you have you watched the episodes
where you won't look you won't look when
I am 82 I will watch it and go how did I
look I look great I have no interesting
well you're very beautiful I think I I
think you have
now do you worry at all this is the
thing that occurs to me sometimes is I
can sometimes when I'm doing something
that's a little racing whatever I
channel my parents you know and I think
there my parents are watching right now
does that ever occur to you when you're
on a show like masters of sex like my
mother your mom is yes my mother
couldn't when I told her I was doing
this show before it came out before she
knew that it was actually a very cool
and respectable show I told her what it
was called and she she couldn't even say
the name of it she would tell her
friends well she's doing the mom show
and then she's doing this other show
with with Beau Bridges and it's it's a
show it's a with the mom show though is
on your life talk about it and I know
she's seen it and she's very proud of my
work on it my father has but we we don't
talk we don't talk about right none of
those things there man do I come from
the same family yeah we don't discuss
anything my parents tell people I'm in
real estate
you